I guess we shine enough I'm not really
sad innocent stuff myself
yeah y'all get it tasted I don't have
navigators I need consistency I had too
much complaining don't do this simple
fun I take this serious exclusives all I
came here just step your pitch in and
get it done
[ __ ] going through motions I tell them
Miss Lee I'll focus on making history
want this for my intensity for you
cannot limit me moments like these are
hard to find
I just want what's mine the crown in the
title don't let me miss you do over rep
and do that like a hundred words four
minutes till no one hear you hard to
hate you walk further left my
confiscated I'm ready I wanted it better
don't none of you scare me where haptic
to a successful maintaining fact that
you made it although that money took you
overcompensating you run for your
friends I rest for the rum I'm up
shaking dreams
you are facing girls too busy FaceTime
and borrowing for I did more than you
win again I know they've got to be off a
million fuels in this DC you boys can't
compete or ever saw that I was awesome
what are you got a partner or now
launching minimal true didn't vlog of
London teacher now hear me I was like I
got to do something first log on any
city business makes me happy no you're
welcome back up yeah yeah okay kill how
are you making - thank you you're
welcome
I don't want Mac for Hannah I'm anything
I said - and much I got the connection
yeah how are saying yeah good
one of the things we're finding I know
the members out here will agree so the
deal is there's the change of narrative
on metrics what's working what's not
working which metrics to look at which
ones they all the [ __ ] cars and the
we're going to do that and the way to do
that is by suffocating the marketing I
want to be in a bake-off with your stuff
my picture can say ask for Rick or
called
you guys know how to get Google phone
numbers get a bunch of Google phone
numbers use Twilio make all your
separate marketing call a different
phone number and then measure it not
only that cause calls aren't sales of
cars then follow through and which you
know you might get eighty calls from
Facebook
you might get 130 phone calls from the
radio but if you sell one car from the
radio and seven from Facebook because
the data you targeted where people
actually in the goddamn market to buy a
car
the reason you guys spend so much money
is you're only spending because you
never know when the person's in
consideration Facebook has data people
searching to buy cars and you can get in
their feed and what's the matter with
people I'll tell you what's the matter
you don't know that truth that I know
you didn't know that you didn't know
that you didn't know the Facebook you
think the stuff that came out the other
day about the FBI and the CIA like
hacking every set yes
like just assume everybody is looking at
you at all times
privacy is dead we're naked you don't
like it
stop using your phone let's see how long
you last so yes it's a huge advantage
and so you know the metric is selling
cars man like you know the reason I want
to paint Instagram influencer who's like
good-looking AB dude or a bleed chick is
because I know 4,000 people show up to
my dealership and three been my buy a
car and I'm willing to make that bet I
have to at least taste it I want to see
what it looks like how are you not
curious you touched on the third let me
tell you how you do it
going to Instagram and search you search
a hashtag like what up and you can just
search actually search I'm sorry you go
into Instagram and there's a search bar
up top you search by location so you put
in your zip code your town it shows you
the 12 most trending pictures within a
one-mile radius of your goddamn town and
then look at all the pictures I promise
you seven of them are attractive scandal
e clad you know the other five or
something else but you click on them you
see how many followers they have their
global it's not like all their followers
are from Alpharetta you know like
they're all over the place but you click
on them and then you there's a triple
little button in the top right corner
that's how you message people you click
it you DM the person and you say I own a
car dealership I'd like to pay you to
show up at my car dealership this
Saturday from 12:00 to 4:00 and you tell
your Instagram followers they'll reply
they'll say how much you say I have no
idea some weird guy told me to do this
how much is it they give you an answer
and then you take a risk you may lose
six hundred dollars you may crap your
pants when they ask you to fifty
thousand dollars and you realize how
real this is and you keep playing and
then you try it and then you learn when
you're a pioneer you have to taste it
there's no report there's no white paper
there's no modeling mixed metrics that
are going to teach you how that's going
to work when you're the first Explorer
you have to taste the berries and
hopefully they're not poisonous
just uh questions risk questions right
here one of experiences
I just contract with for the paper I
don't need no one's favorite and that'll
[ __ ] with maybe
America my friend we work for them are
in the very position they say is not a
cool thing with using my dictionary and
I came from Soviet Union to I love it
please hi everybody one life don't worry
about your accent to see you
your truth is your truth they'll love
you as long as it's your truth 20 - uh -
or as I am - I want a quick challenge
leaderboard because I've already tripped
you really have that man awesome when
you made it my Brotherhood
nothing real talent it is a blossom ever
get yeah vaynermedia is fearless because
I'm fearless but I'm in charge so it's
one of the things it's always here it's
the fear of the unknown it's short term
thinking versus long term thinking it's
acting like the world's I mean tomorrow
when for the far majority of us will be
here 30 40 50 60 years from now what
CEOs and business owners have done a
good job with crushing big companies is
somehow manipulate the conversation that
it's not fair for one who spoke is it
like it's his fault it's his fault it's
my fault like if you're in charge in
your [ __ ] it's your fault so no I don't
see a difference between people and
organizations because the organization
is calling the lead of the singular
decision-making by the weapon I know I
just go ahead
yes I'm put your put your arm out to the
world at scale at you I mean every
goddamn day on every platform always
you're always one Instagram post one
Facebook post one snapchat post one blog
post away from somebody thinking it's
great all right does that make sense yes
it does
I know love you do that
I had a bottle and bye-bye that means
that's the stupidest buying followers is
the single stupidest thing to do because
I'll tell you why
it gets you nothing other than
perception meanwhile everybody smart
like nobody who's ever bought a follower
has ever tricked me that they bought
followers so what happens when you buy
followers is the top 10% of smartest
people who can bring you the most value
in the world think that you're a scam
artist so maybe you tricked the bottom
10% so when you buy followers you're up
the elevator thank you guys thank you so
much
so you're welcome bro hell yeah okay so
well thank you guys take care um buying
follows isn't isn't Santa you know like
don't you're worried about other people
yes I definitely worry already going to
judgment and embarrassed about my
follower calves right now don't we all
started there you're wrapping your
self-esteem into the following count is
is a huge mistake
don't buy followers don't cut corners
you got any patience in such a breathing
so much like I do you're [ __ ] crazy
don't worry about that like you got to
care about stay inside yourself
okay I I respect you so much more for
having 97 followers that are yours then
somebody who bought a bunch and I can
tell because their engagement rate is
[ __ ] compared to how many followers they
have you understand yeah yeah I do those
guys they'll talk to their followers or
anything
patience patience and inside yourself
nobody else inside yourself patience
inside yourself patience that's it
eight Gary is really nice to meet like
the name is Bianca hi Bianca
thank you guys take care I'm safe
travels
[Music]
and
[Music]
you
[Music]
a honey Empire was all the way through
life at this point as you guys know
60-second clubs a lot of t-shirts a lot
of books but also a lot of - and
five-minute face times so about three in
right now I'm about to do a job here we
go
a job so para kadala
listen Vaynerchuk this picture - you're
an engineer
that's right makes sense your Pratt your
practical and entrepreneurship
I would tell you them to level up you're
thinking I wouldn't think about it as
wedding pedis birthday I would think of
your main thing is just calligraphy
[Music]
but this one on a huge email floor my
desk email ran to the whole company I
felt like how many didn't get the rock
like
well it's only 54 emails in the whole
company and and it was great huge
communication thing about speed and
efficiency some of you might have saw my
tweet that started it then I got going
and got a lot done in an hour and a half
on email I will impact for our company
for a long time
nice huh
[Music]
by the way for everybody at home this
hole to do about the mazes whether it's
59 New York feel like people be sad
[Music]
please just like the book this is what
I'm always my chiefest like my desk like
this that's my you know you know you've
always been very smart to trade on me
during those times and I actually
believe I can buyer that and other the
smart give it some gimmicks give it some
thought I'm willing to you know always
jam with you number two and this was
interesting
do you guys have an agency or do you do
all your creative marketing and media
work in Prudhoe
[Music]
love above talk about four minutes to
monster things four minutes
[ __ ] put both times there start done
put some music on this friggin super try
to speak a word or two in four minutes
two monster things not 15 not 30 not
presentations not PDFs human words four
minutes execution
[Music]
hello Alice can I turn your ball let's
applaud your real pleasure are you Robin
how are you it's a pleasure
well they have you protects personal
things I was going so far really quite
good Hey oh yeah it's such a pleasure
yeah hey guys hi how are you see you
later
hello yo-yo
okay fantastic
you yellow pumps champ
what's up any all right couple emails
couple emails
I'm on it and feel good about myself
yeah real pleasure in it how are you yes
thank you
- in 14 minutes I listen I'll take one
half day and return throat what it does
subsets my arch-nemesis the only person
is going to prayer being in this here it
can be me and you kiddo
barring injury hey guys
technology choice want me Capri
but I'm open I'm open for business hey
boy run of your life yep you can send
our email present to them yeah like like
right now yes yeah
that's clearly bubbling SATs or stomach
sleepers all right
okay how's life feel really good that
some things off my chest feeling good
everybody need to be in with me now this
is a good-looking meeting this is a
good-looking meeting this is the kind of
meeting I like to people is a very good
number
Chris MD conference room all of a sudden
we of them's an African crazy how that
works out ah my second meeting to human
being
[Music]
okay killing great love it yeah look
again I want to go into Valhalla
yeah then no that's exterior video if
you look in the background like yeah you
go to background so they sure can you
get a some excuse on how you hate those
countries actually don't really bother
me maybe I'll that's really no random
marshals a giant opposing the public
oh god this is insane oh uh huh she's
really cool I saw this with my life
story uh I mean we're probably gonna
have to frame it yeah explain it who
made it okay hold it up real quick
it's a quilt right yeah this thing is
insane but they get a shout out a
wonderful person that made it sick
[Music]
preview tab is Bev Sunday it's going to
be the main theme vaynermedia doing an
alumni program one of the great things
about this company is have so many
incredible people who after three four
or five years or sometimes even after
six months or after working in agencies
fifteen years and with six months here
they know this is the Pentagon they're
like oh it wasn't my agency it's just an
agency like a lot of small businesses a
lot of large businesses we're creating
an incredible thing part of the honey
Empire an internal um Knight program
where people can raise your hand all
these startups I'm involved with all of
you people looking for talent our way
this whole you know digital 2017 camp
thing that we've been talking about the
tours the 10,000 hours ahead is another
layer another big idea alumni program if
you're a company that's looking to hire
unbelievable talent all disciplines
we're going to it's gonna be cool when
somebody comes to us or or when we
decide somebody's not part of the team
anymore we're gonna put them in this
alumni funnel and they're gonna shoot
out to be really cool I'm pretty excited
about changing the way HR and job
hunting and the whole thing works and so
it's a little quick little preview in
today's day only be for what you'll
definitely see Sunday
you
yes
yeah yeah how easy care easy mr.
pleasure narsing buddy you're like I
don't you miss hi
the free miss Tyler yes hello is not the
power you've been telling me that's a
Polish man
we have emotional so this Tyler is not
happy just filming a little B role and
that's it for my blog so but if that's
not okay that's fine you know today is
awesome it is awesome not many mothers
know I mean Google is arrange stuff like
that to no man be so quickly if we can
actually put everything out there like
the real real stuff
I want you to keep that part in this
episode the real stuff yep I'm given the
team 97% real what Pavan is talking
about is the insanely difficult [ __ ] I'm
dealing with I can't share because um
because of just involving people's lives
and it's inappropriate for me to do so
now that being said it's important for
me to continue the reference than I do
for you guys so that you guys know that
but like there's just nothing but
adversity and difficulty you know to say
I'm a firefighter when you're the CEO
it's all your fault
everything's on you and
yeah I think what's interesting
resembling the users clip is your
perspective interesting because it's
fresh eyes you're like oh this is what
it is it's real [ __ ] grass is always
greener damn I got to be signing up I'm
not really shot Anderson suck my [ __ ]
yeah
young annotation I don't have cabbage
shakers
I need consistency I had too much
complaining don't do this simple fun I
take this chairs exclusives all I came
here just stop the bitching and get it
done
[ __ ] going through motions I'm telling
miss Lee a focus on making this that we
want this for my intensity Brooks you
cannot let any moments like these are
hard to find
I just want what's mine